bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission à trois semaines du
scrutin nous avons décidé de nous mettre
à l'heure de la campagne pour les
européennes avec des politologues des
journalistes dans cette émission
direction l'allemagne le bon élève de
l'europe le champion toutes catégories
confondues un budget une balance
commerciale excédentaire à tout chômage
sous la barre des 7% et une croissance
estimée à 1 8 % en 2014 mais il y a un
mais le modèle allemand c'est là où le
bas salaires blesse avec des
travailleurs pour qu'attendent ces
millions de salariés précaires de ces
élections européennes c'est ce que nous
verrons tout à l'heure mais avant un
tout autre sujet à quoi va ressembler le
prochain parlement européen après le
scrutin du 25 mai en attendant les
résultats officiels on a on a on a des
sondages les dernières estimations
issues des derniers sondages s'est tout
de suite
principal groupe au parlement européen
la droite et le centre
le ppe auquel appartient l'ump ils
pointent en tête dans huit pays dont
l'allemagne et l'espagne
le groupe socialiste et démocrate auquel
appartient le ps voit lui c'est parti en
pole position dans neuf pays dont le
royaume uni et l'italie
l'un de ses chefs martin schulz et
candidat à la présidence de la
commission je donnais l'europe dans une
autre direction tourner le dos à ces
inégalités insupportables en europe les
grands profiteurs ils ont des milliards
des profits et ne paient pas de taxes et
quand ils font des milliards de pertes
ce sont les contribuables qui payent
pour eu assez peur juste la gauche
unitaire dont est membre le front de
gauche arrive en première place en grèce
les écolos atteignent le sommet du
classement en belgique
l'extrême droite fait son meilleur score
en france aux pays bas en république
tchèque en pologne et au danemark la
plupart d'entre eux été membre d'aucun
groupe lors de la dernière mandature des
non-inscrits comme le front national
si le peuple français nous placent en
tête le 25 mai prochain le président de
la république ne pourra pas ignorer ne
rejet de la construction européenne qui
se sera exprimée en france pour l'heure
deux sondages ont été réalisés dans des
circonscriptions françaises puis une
enquête ifop donne florian philippot
front national en tête dans l'est juste
devant l'ump nadine morano dans le sud
est le rapport est inversé selon une
autre enquête l'ump renaud muselier
devance le frontiste jean-marie le pen
loin devant le socialiste vincent
peillon
alors trois invités m'ont rejoint
françois forest bonjour vous êtes
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'ulb l'université libre de bruxelles à
vos côtés tom weingartner bonjour vous
êtes journaliste de la radio publique
allemande et easter road font qu à vos
côtés route berrichonne second jour du
quotidien allemand handelsblatt alors
vous venez de voir ce petit reportage ce
sondage ce premier sondage ça n'est
qu'un sondage qu'est ce qui vous inspire
conçoit faudrait
d'abord que ça ne va pas être simple de
gérer cette diversité après l'élection à
chaud il ya quand même des éléments
intéressants qui ressort je crois on
voit tout de même l'influencent de la
personnalisation du scrutin lié
évidemment au nouveau mécanisme liant la
désignation du président de la
commission aux résultats des élections
européennes voir martin schulz par
exemple tenir un tel discours accentué
tionnement idéologique notamment en
allant vers une gauche un peu plus
musclé je crois qu'on voit là clairement
une dynamique le transnational parce
qu'il n'est pas sûr qu'un tel discours
en allemagne rencontre un accueil un
accueil tout à fait enthousiaste ça mais
mes collègues spécialistes de l'art et
que parce que
pour leurs discours
et c'est une forme d'européanisation on
voit que les leaders ont conscience que
maintenant il s'adresse un peu plus
qu'avant encore à un public européen les
campagnes restent très national les
listes restent aussi très nationale mais
on voit quand même je crois cela se gère
milliers à la personnalisation qui veut
dire aussi organisation route bien la
berrichonne l'allemagne le père placé en
tête en allemagne oui bon c'est pas une
série à nouveau c'est pas du tout une
surprise puisque la chancelière marque
toujours un gouvernent déjà depuis 8 ans
9 ans maintenant elle est toujours très
populaire en allemagne et c'est dû à ce
fait que la queue leu les chrétiens
démocrates sont toujours largement en
tête les social démocrates sont bien
derrière bien tard et c'est pour le
candidat souhaite certainement une
déception puisqu'il est en allemand il
est candidat
au poste du président de la commission
et pourtant ça ne veut pas dire que les
social démocrates auront un succès
électoral en allemagne
tom gardner oui je pense
c'est tout à fait ça les les partenaires
les parties aussi les partis
eurosceptiques font aussi en allemagne
sont sont très forts annuellement et les
partis traditionnels aussi ils
reprennent certaines
parties de leurs discours partir mans
par exemple l'aller les conservateurs en
bavière sont aussi font aussi une
compagne entre
eurocritique
qui rejette certaines côté de l'union
européenne et donc on voit l'extrême
droite qui fait qu'ils feraient de bons
scores donc en france aux pays bas en
république tchèque en pologne et au
danemark ça vous inspire quoi on dit que
ce sera le premier parti de ces
élections
vraiment ça me fait un petit peur
surtout pour la france puisque la france
est quand même la patrie de la
démocratie en europe si j'ose dire c'est
la france où s'est passée la révolution
française et c'est pour ça que j'ai un
peu peur pour la république rappelle
puisque si le front dans la riveraine
tête en france qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est quand même c'est une image
c'est une catastrophe pour l'image de la
france en europe ce serait une
catastrophe et sa sortie pour l'europe
entière un très mauvais message et c'est
pour ça puisque le front national n'est
pas un parti majorité en france est un
parti minoritaire en france et pourquoi
est ce que ce parti peut arriver en tête
peut-être parce que les gens ne vont pas
voter et j'espère vraiment ça c'est
vraiment je perds fort que les français
vont voter pour empêcher le front
national d'arriver en être aux élections
européennes françois forest c'est
possible c'est parti populiste que ces
partis populistes soit les gagnants de
ces élections européennes qu'il remporte
un succès certainement c'est indéniable
entend dire qu'il serait par exemple le
premier est parti c'est déjà dire qu'il
sera imparti or je crois que ce qu'on
voit aussi c'est l'extrême diversité de
ses forces et quand on met d'abord la
nation en avant il est compliqué de
parler d'europe et pourtant je trouve
qu'il parle d'europe alors peut-être
suis-je d'un optimisme indécrottable
mais on voit aussi que même l'extrême
droite doit constituer des alliances
doit intégrer l'europe comme horizon
même pour la critique est donc d'abord
c'est pas un phénomène radicalement
nouveau en nature en 2 grèce certes bon
c'est parti là étaient présents
auparavant donc je crois qu'il ya pas de
rupture après il faudra voir une fois
dans le jeu européen ce qu'ils vont
faire moi je ne suis pas aussi
catastrophiste parce que s'ils veulent
exister de toute façon il faudra
composer avec les règles du jeu du jeu
européen mais c'est un signal à entendre
évidemment autre question est
d'actualité celle là la france at elle
une chance de devenir un des bons élèves
de l'europe la commission de bruxelles a
donc commencé à examiner le projet de
budget de paris pour les mois et les
années qui viennent verdict des experts
il ne croit pas aux engagements du
gouvernement de revenir à 3% du déficit
l'an prochain mais ils reconnaissent
qu'il y a un léger mieux regarder
et voici bruxelles qui douche les
espoirs de la france trois fois par an
la commission européenne présente ses
prévisions économiques pour les 28 pays
de l'union une nouvelle fois bruxelles
est moins optimiste que la france pour
cette année elle prévoit une croissance
française de 1 % comme le gouvernement
mais en 2015 ce sera 1,5 pour cent
seulement soit moins que les prévisions
de l'équipe de manuel valls et c'est
surtout sur le déficit que la commission
ne fait pas confiance à la france il
sera selon elle de 3 9% cette année et
de 3 4% en 2015 elle ne croit donc pas à
la promesse d'atteindre l'an prochain
les sacro-saints 3% du pacte de
responsabilité
pour son premier déplacement à bruxelles
le nouveau ministre des finances l'a sur
bruxelles ne sait pas tout la commission
a fait un travail de prévision à partir
d'un certain nombre d'éléments mais bien
entendu pas de la totalité des éléments
qu'elle l'ordre à apprendre et donc une
journée de travail comme celle ci met
très utile elle me permet de décrire
précisément où les aspects du pacte de
responsabilité
point positif néanmoins la commission
européenne prévoit pour l'an prochain
une très légère baisse du chômage
voilà et pour être complet sur
l'ensemble de la zone euro la commission
européenne anticipe désormais une
croissance de 1,7 pour cent pour la zone
euro en 2015 contre 1,8 pour cent
précédemment donc une anticipation à la
baisse première question toute simple
est ce que est ce que c'est possible que
la france soit sanctionné
oui c'est possible après on atteint un
niveau vraiment politique là la
commission c'est son travail elle exerce
le mandat qu'on lui a donnée est ce
qu'il fallait lui donner c'est la
lumière qui les sanctionner voilà mais
après je crois qu'il ya la dimension
proprement politique il ya ce qu'il
faudrait faire d'après les textes et
puis il ya ce qui ne faudrait pas faire
en termes politiques donc comme souvent
je pense que ça va se traduire par un
compromis où les intérêts de chacun sont
sont respectées mais il faut quand même
aussi tenir compte qu'on a pris des
engagements et quand on exige de la
grèce qu'elle respecte ses engagements
la france est d'accord quand ses
partenaires exige de la france qu'elle
respecte les siens on renâcle bon c'est
humain mais il faut aussi quand même
voir dans le long terme quel regard au
delà en allemagne sur ses engagements
pris par la france
si j'ose dire tu es un petit peu de
patience la jyske on a quand même des
règles budgétaires en europe et on a
déjà deux fois donner plus de temps à la
france pour arriver aux 3% et maintenant
une troisième fois est ce qu'on n'a pas
donné une troisième fois à nouveau délai
j'en sors je suis pas certaine et je
pense que peut-être l'allemagne ça va
dépendre un petit peu de la volonté
politique en france y poursuivre les
réformes que le président de la
république a annoncé paris il ya quand
même des réformes que je trouve ce sont
des bonnes réformes par exemple la
réforme territoriale
c'est une grande réforme et on va bien
mary fier à bruxelles si la france dit
mince en ce qui concerne la forme et
dans ce cas là si elle le fait je pense
qu'un troisième une troisième reconduite
ce soit possible
tom weingartner une allemagne la
patiente vis-à-vis des engagements
français ne respectez pas moi je crois
d'éducation les allemands je crois vont
insister
que
la france va tenir ses engagements je
crois aussi ce serait un très mauvais
signe pour le pacte de stabilité et tous
ces pactes qu'on a fait là dans les
dernières années pour stabiliser
l'économie ce serait un très mauvais
signe si les français échapperait là à
leurs engagements et s'ils tiennent pas
aussi à des sanctions parce que là le
pacte de stabilité seraient morts donc
on a parlé de ses prévisions de
croissance donc à la baisse une
politique donc aussi d'austérité assumer
par bruxelles est-ce que c'est pas ça
qui va faire des dégâts le 25 mai
prochain aux élections
budgétaire il à dire la politique de
rigueur en grèce là la gauche unitaire
dans les sondages et c'est vrai que d'un
côté la politique c'est vrai que la
politique de rigueur est pas populaire
c'est vrai que si on si on coupe dans
les dépenses publiques ce n'est pas
populaire ça c'est évidemment comme ça
mais d'un autre côté si la dette monte
monte monte on a vu pendant la crise de
l'euro ce que ça donne on a vu qu'il ya
des pays membres de la zone euro qui
n'arrivent plus à se financer ou
autonomes eux-mêmes qui ont besoin du
soutien des autres
donc ça c'est pas vraiment une voix
et c'est pas une bonne chose et c'est
pour ça mon avis que chaque pays aussi
la france doit réfléchir comment gérer
sa dette publique on voit bien que cette
politique ne fonctionne pas en bois la
france à un déficit bien supérieur à ce
qui est permis et la croissance est tout
même pas là alors ça fonctionne pas
justement parlons de l'allemagne il
s'agit du bon élève de l'europe le
champion toutes catégories confondues
donc un budget et une balance
commerciale excédentaire à tous le
chômage sous la barre des 7% une
croissance estimée à 20 8% en 2014 mais
le modèle amant c'est aussi les mini
jobs et les bas salaires quel est le
prix de cette compétitivité exemplaires
en zone euro 14 6 millions de salariés
précaires pauvres de ces élections
européennes regardez le reportage de
gernot andrieu
voici le bon élève européen le modèle
allemand ici le salaire minimum a été
votée mais n'est pas encore appliquée
l'allemagne c'est huit millions de
salariés gagnant moins de huit euros
brut de l'heure l'autre visage du
miracle allemand ce sont les mini jobs
15 à 20 heures de travail hebdomadaire
pour 400 euros par mois t as many diop
il ya beaucoup de personnes ici avec un
mini jobs mais il vaudrait mieux qu'ils
trouvent un vrai boulot avec un vrai
salaire les employeurs préfèrent surtout
donner des mini jobs car pour eux c'est
moins de contraintes
si l'allemagne est en bonne santé
économique c'est aussi grâce à sa
réforme du marché du travail en 2003
avec gerhard schröder dans ce centre
sportif ce patron emploi une partie de
ses salariés grâce aux contrats mini
jobs une souplesse indispensable pour
son activité
mon point de vue c'est que tout cela a
apporté plus de possibilités et de
flexibilité aux entrepreneurs mais cela
a aussi permis à des personnes au
chômage ou en situation précaire
de retrouver un emploi
ces mini jobs elisabeth les connaît par
coeur informatique centre d'appel ou
restauration pour elle c'est toujours le
même contrat et elle vient de perdre son
dernier emploi voilà c'est le restaurant
dans lequel je arrière 20
je travaillais ici comme serveuse j'ai
aussi aidé un peu en cuisine je gagnais
7 euros de l'heure sans compter les
pourboires à l'arrivée ça faisait un
salaire correct mais pas fantastique
déçu mais pas inquiète retrouver un
travail ici n'est pas vraiment difficile
il suffit de franchir la porte d'un job
center ici vous avez la description du
poste et les compétences requises et
voilà votre salaire 450 euros par mois
et vous pouvez me dire combien je vais
gagner pas rare non ce n'est pas indiqué
les inconvénients ce sont surtout les
conditions de licenciement l'assurance
maladie les vacances en fait on n'a
aucun droit et on doit souvent changé de
job en ce qui me concerne j'ai déjà été
licenciés où j'ai dû arrêter parce que
les horaires ne m'allait plus bref il
faut toujours rester flexible
au delà de cette flexibilité des mini
jobs le secret de la compétitivité
allemande ce sont aussi les millions
d'emplois non qualifiés et payé bien en
dessous du salaire minimum envisagée à 8
euros 50 en france il est à 9 euros 50
de l'heure alors à berlin on espère une
avancée sociale grâce à l'europe ce soit
lisabeth assiste à une réunion du spd
sur ce que l'europe peut lui apporter
pour commencer je vous propose un petit
rappel sur le fonctionnement de l'europe
au programme beaucoup de pédagogie mme
elisabeth n'est pas vraiment convaincu
moi je pense que ces grands partis ne
sont pas vraiment la solution car il
parle surtout entre eux alors que les
petits partis sont plus proches des gens
j'espère vraiment qu'un salaire minimum
va être mise en place et qu'avec
l'europe tout cela fonctionne un jour
après la rigueur de gerhard schröder les
travailleurs pauvres allemand espère de
l'europe plus d'harmonisation sociale
qu'il faudra encore patienter le salaire
minimum ne sera pas mise en place avant
le 1er janvier 2017
voilà reportage signé germain andrieu je
vais m'adresser tout de suite à mes
invités journalistes allemands alors ces
mini jobs ou peut se faire licencier
facilement où on est payé à 450 euros le
mois cette flexibilité c'est ça le prix
à payer pour être le bon élève de
l'europe je pense une partie oui c'est
ça et avec le avec les salaires minimums
il faut voir que nature moins une partie
des dépôts ce qui existe aujourd'hui
vont disparaître il ya bien pas votre
question certaines parties des
entreprises vont être capables de passer
des coûts supplémentaires à leurs
clients mais ceux qui ne peuvent pas
faire ça vont supprimer ces postes alors
c'est à dire ce sera pas bon pour
l'emploi c'est un fait une concession
pour la politique sociale c'est bien et
moi je suis pas contre le salaire
minimum mais je crois pour l'emploi ça
va payer on va payer un prix
c'est vrai que
peut-être le monsieur schröder alors
l'ancien chancelier un peu exagéré avec
ses réformes de la politique sociale
avec son agente à 2010 commence à sapin
chez nous et c'est vrai qu'il a exagéré
parce que quand même le travail précaire
a énormément augmenté ces
salariés maintenant le gouvernement à
corriger un petit peu le cap et on va
introduire la smic en 2010 est de ceux
qui ce qui était évoqué dans mon petit
fils pourtant c'est une bonne chose
notre côté il ya aussi beaucoup de
critiques en ce qui concerne le smic en
allemagne est ce que mon collègue vient
d'évoquer par exemple dans l'allemagne
de l'est les les salaires générale sont
beaucoup plus bas qu'on loi qu'à l'ouest
l'allemagne est peut-être beaucoup par
exemple les coiffeuses c'est une c'est
une c'est un exemple vont peut-être
maintenant perdre leur emploi parce que
à ce niveau de salaire donc c'est une
organisation sociale parce que c'est une
harmonisation sociale vis-à-vis des
voisins européens ont oscillé de
l'établissement ce smic ou penser que ça
va être négatif pour pour l'allemagne ce
mix négatif pour l'allemagne
c'est un côté c'est positif
si je suis d'accord avec cette analyse
que ça peut coûter des emplois en
allemagne c'est aussi une vérité je vous
souhaite une harmonisation par rapport à
l'est par exemple peut-être par rapport
à la france où le smic et à 9,50 mais
par rapport à la pologne nature montrent
plutôt la différence et si on compare la
situation en france et en allemagne
c'est vrai qu'on a on a des gens qui
travaillent qui sont pauvres mais en
fait on a le choix entre les projets
forest quel regard vous portez sur le
modèle allemand je n'ai pas l'expertisé
de la société allemande de mes collègues
mais ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
que c'est l'allemagne décrite comme le
chantre de la rigueur qui ramène sur
l'agenda européen le débat sur le
salaire minimum
harmonisation sociale je crois qu'il
faut attendre un peu avant d'en parler
mais en tout cas voilà ça y est on est
dans le dur dans l'intégration
européenne jusqu'à présent on a mis en
relation des marchés est maintenant
s'ouvre le débat sur finalement le
modèle social un qui doit contrebalancer
l'intégration par le marché alors c'est
un débat très difficile on voit bien
quand on parle de salaire minimal on ne
dit pas du tout la même chose selon les
pays mais enfin on pose cette question
des valeurs et de la solidarité au
fondement de leur politique on ne fait
qu'effleurer le débat dans les élections
européennes actuelles mais je trouve que
c'est aussi une avancée et c'est un
débat qui va prendre des années et c'est
un débat qui va déchirer laurent est ce
que c'est parce que les peuples qu'on
parle un peu de 2,2 ce stade
nécessairement que d'économie mais qu'on
parle aussi de ceux de leurs conditions
de vie de social va certainement
inévitable à la longue nature man city
on a une union monétaire une union
économique le
le problème d'avoir des des standards
sociaux se pose naturellement mais il
faut voir que les les fondements pour un
système social sont très différents à
des niveaux très différents c'est à dire
avant de
d'harmoniser par exemple ce qui est la
discussion une assurance chômage contre
la bulgarie et
le long de ça il ya des mondes par
exemple si on parle de la
d'harmonisation rue par exemple le smic
les smicards parleurs en france c'est 9
euros 50 en allemagne ça sera peut-être
limité à 8 58 50 en grèce ou au portugal
c'est beaucoup moi c'est peut-être six
mois je sais qu'on n'est pas le chiffre
exact mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'harmonisation ça veut dire un smic
inférieur qu'aujourd'hui en france ça
c'est la suite la rédaction d'accord
c'est le modèle français qui devrait se
rabaisser
le un oui mais la réalisation ça veut
dire qu'on se retrouve au milieu
c'est toujours ça mais si je peux me
permettre dans le reportage trouve qu'il
était mentionné des attentes placées en
l'europe pour en quelque sorte renforcer
la dimension sociale dans la politique
nationale je crois que c'est là le vrai
défi pour l'union européenne concernant
les droits fondamentaux par exemple
l'union européenne et considéré dans
beaucoup de pays comme un rempart contre
d'éventuels abus des pouvoirs nationaux
si l'europe arrive à jouer ce rôle-là en
matière sociale ça sera un renversement
complet de l'image actuelle de l'union
européenne c'est là le défi évidemment
ça sera sûrement pas un salaire minimal
unique le même dans tous les pays
européens mais là il ya un défi
constitutif pour l'union européenne je
crois pas qu'elle puisse l'annoncé de
ces de la compétence exclusive des états
c'est la politique sociale et dans un
cadre de coordination qui fait que
l'europe pèse quand même
de temps certes d'accord allez on
termine avec le happy voting ou quand
l'europe veut mobiliser à ses troupes
pour les élections européennes appuyez
voting sait on se pose la question
est-ce que c'est par med à l'abstention
des jeunes regarder ça swingue
il fait
voilà rapide voting l'abstention surtout
l'abstention des jeunes c'est ce qu'on
craint pour le vannes ça mais cette
abstention c'est possible ou forte
abstention on s'affairait à oui c'est
possible c'est même probable moi je suis
toujours content de voir des jeunes qui
s'amusent mais faut pas prendre les
jeunes pour des imbéciles non plus de
riz voilà le vote c'est sérieux et je
crois que les jeunes se mobilisent aussi
tout à fait pour des raisons sérieuses
mais c'est très bien que ça existe ce
genre mais on se sent pas un engouement
alors cette campagne est là
dans cette campagne
lectorale européenne comment vous la
voyez
en france elle intervient juste après
des municipales
alors la campagne électorale on doit le
dire n'est pas hyper passionnante c'est
sur mais bon pourquoi un taux
d'abstention aussi élevé à mon avis la
raison c'est on ne peut pas réparer avec
une campagne électorale qui dure un mois
les les dégâts qu'on a fait pendant des
années avant les vacances ça veut dire
que les politiques surtout les
politiques nationaux en allemagne en
france pour pratiquement doubler par
alors par très mauvais de l'union
européenne on accuse tous les temps
bruxelles les institutions européennes
quand quelque chose ne va pas et on
arrive à faire dans les médias dans vos
médias respectifs vous arrivez à vendre
leur arrivée
on essaie mais de toute façon on a
durement et nous on fait pas la
politique c'est à dire si les
politiciens nationaux au fond l'union
européen le bouc émissaire pour pour
tous les maux qu'ils ont su
nous on peut qu'à réparer ça moi je
crois qu'il ya un élément qui qui qui me
rend un peu plus optimistes entre
guillemets je veux dire pour le pour le
vote c'est la crise on ukraine moi je
pourrais m'imaginer que notamment dans
les pays de l'est ça va augmenter le
taux de participation éventuellement
parce que nature mon ses paysages son
tir
se sont plus concernés et ce sont ce
refuge un peu vers l'europe avec les
menaces qu'ils ont à leur frontière est
merci en tout cas à mes trois invités
d'avoir accepté notre invitation c'est
la fa d'europe hebdo merci d'avoir suivi
bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
ouais